dans six semaines nous retourneront aux
urnes pour désigner nos prochains mère
merci de nous rejoindre pour cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 politiques
spéciales municipal 2020 comme chaque
semaine aujourd'hui je reçois olivier
bonsoir bonsoir et bienvenue sur ce
plateau vous êtes tête de liste unie
pour voisin à voisins le bretonneux
donc je reviens sur la dernière élection
qui était en 2015 et non plus en 2014
puisqu'il ya vu un recours déposé par
l'un des candidats battus ils avaient
obtenu gain de cause à l'ancien maire
alexis piette à ce moment là lors de la
nouvelle élection qui avait été
provoquée en 2015 il ne s'est pas
présenté il y avait plusieurs listes de
différentes tendances et quelquefois de
tendance très similaire et vous n'aviez
pas fait équipe à l'époque avec thierry
gastaud étiez candidat thierry gastou ne
l'était pas et il était aussi mais pas
avec vous qu'est ce qui vous a réuni
cette fois ci puisque vous serez
ensemble alors d'abord on est ensemble
et ont le doigt parce que tirer gastou a
considéré que j'étais le mieux placé
cette année alors j'ai cette année parce
qu'on a l'impression d'avoir des
élections tout le temps à voisins et je
l'en remercie parce qu'en fait il a joué
la carte je pense du gagnant gagnant il
faut que larry fallait clarifier l'offre
politique à voisins on attend on a été
souvent habitué à avoir beaucoup de
listes donc cette fois ci on a une liste
claire et nette c'est sur le cadre de
vie ce qui nous a rapprochés c'est le
vote concernant le plan local d'habitat
intercommunale ou mme alexandra rosetti
nous a clairement indiqué qu'elle
prévoyait plus de 1000 logements
enfin vous alentours de 1000 logements
pardon c'est après qu'on a découvert
qu'elle n'allait plus dans les cinq ans
à venir
et là je pense qu'on a on a vraiment eu
un déclic sert que pour nous l'intérêt
de la vi la ville pardon ils passent
avant nos intérêts personnels ou où nos
carrières entre guillemets politique ça
permet aussi de clarifier l'offre
politique se ravise puisqu'on a pris
aussi la déclaration d'une troisième
liste plus à gauche cette fois ci donc
il devrait y avoir trois listes sur
voisins le bretonneux pour autant
expliquer nous aujourd'hui ce qui vous
différencie de la mer alexandra rosetti
udi qui elle siège au sein de la
majorité de saint quentin en yvelines
avec des gens finalement du même bord
politique le plus ou moins que que vous
qu'est ce qui fait la différence entre
votre candidature et celle d'alexandra
rosetti par exemple 19 ans de mandat
c'est la différence c'est à dire que
j'ai
je suis élu depuis cinq ans j'ai un
regard plutôt neuf sur les affaires de
la commune et c'est pour moi mon avis
une chance avec sarah rosetti ça fait
déjà dix neuf ans qu'elle est aux
responsabilités précises jettent alors
tombé le premier round de l'ancien maire
je pense qu'on a
voilà c'est pas rien d'être première
adjointe donc elle a été aux
responsabilités pendant 19 ans est en
définitive en tant que maire le bilan
est simple sur tous les sujets qui
structurent notre vie locale j'estime
que le bilan est mauvais vous prenez la
circulation elle avait promis et je dis
bien promis parce que je m'en tiens au
fait je suis très factuelle et premier
contournement voisins par le sud
elle a fait rêver les vies si noah
pendant cinq ans échec total
on a perdu 6 ans c'est pas rien elle
avait promis la réouverture du commerce
de proximité à la grande île il
suffisait de les lire
résultat des courses il y aura des
logements probablement un centre médical
laissez pas encore acté il faudra
soutenir ce projet sinon je sens le 100
% logement le cadre de vie s'est
dégradée la ville les entretiens les
espaces verts ne sont pas rentrer
correctement
il ya un vrai problème et je dirais qui
a un autre souci qu'on n'avait pas
forcément avancer le problème de la
démocratie locale
c'est à dire qu'il y a eu une gestion à
la petite semaine en catimini et dans
l'antre soit qui a conduit souvent d'un
élan avoir des collectifs qui se sont
créés parce qu'il y avait des décisions
qui étaient imposées le cimetière par
exemple et paddle 350000 euros mis sur
la table pour 100 études au préalable et
encore je suis gentil sans étude
préalable
voilà si vous voulez ce qui me
différencie avec elle c'est que je pense
que un élu d'abord est un élu de
proximité
aujourd'hui vous l'avez dit elle kull
différents mandats et moi pour ma part
je suis hostile au cumul des mandats et
c'est bien pour ça que j'ai dit je siège
reste bien évidemment si je suis élu
maire je ne siégerai la communauté d
agglomération aucune décision sera prise
sans mon accord c'est une évidence pour
autant je ne serai pas vice-président de
la communauté d'agglomération
je crois qu un maire doit être investie
pleinement dans sa commune et la
dispersion des mandats c'est évidemment
on est responsable de tout et de rien
on cumule quoi parlons de vos
propositions vous avez évoqué ce bilan
de la maire sortante votre regard sur
son bilan
aujourd'hui vous parliez des transports
on sait que c'est un problème aussi
récurrent sur voisins le bretonneux
quelles sont vos propositions concrètes
pour le transport sur la commune pour
moi d'abord effectivement le problème
majeur c'est la circulation c'est pour
ça d'ailleurs c'est pour cela que nous
avons commencé avec mon équipe et
thierry gastaud par un document en
évoquant différentes pistes de solution
on s'est pas projeté sur une mandature
on a une vision à 15 20 ans donc on
propose différents groupements propose
différentes solutions pardon je vais pas
revenir là parce que ces techniques mais
ce sont des projets qui lobe la plupart
existaient déjà et qu'on n'a pas eu la
volonté
j'irai à la volonté le courage politique
de les mettre en oeuvre
donc aujourd'hui je propose entre autres
des tunnels et fluidifier sur tous les
grands axes pour éviter d'avoir le
passage dans le quartier
donc j'invite les lévy sinois qui
veulent consulter les propositions à se
joindre à aller sur un site internet ils
verront directement mais tout cela doit
se faire on doit avoir un projet global
qui doit se faire à à 15 20 ans or
aujourd'hui ce qu'est ce qu'on constate
on a un problème de transport c'est
évident il va falloir en discuter avec
la communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
on a un manque de communication avec les
autres communes je n'ai pas vu
aujourd'hui une réunion avec les
différents maires des communes de
manille guyancourt montigny et voisins
pour aborder ce sujet là j'ai
l'impression qu'on ne se parle pas j'ai
lu dans un document que madame rose et
ya mis cinq ans pour mettre autour de la
table
quelqu'un du département est quelqu'un
de l'agglo cinq ans pour mettre
quelqu'un autour de la table résultat
rien ne s'est passé
donc moi c'est clair j'ai un projet je
ne le ferai pas dans le dos des vies si
noir on le fera ensemble parce que la
concertation ça fait partie de mon adn
mais par contre je le dis clairement ça
va être six ans à préparer les
structures pour mettre en place ces
solutions je n'ai pas de vision enfin
j'ai mon échéance à moi c'est pas dans
six ans la fin du mandat
c'est au delà néanmoins il faut financer
tout ça on pourrait on va évoquer aussi
quelques unes des autres propositions au
cours des prochaines minutes mais
comment vous financer tout ça parce que
aujourd'hui un désengagement de l'état
et tafer pendant cette campagne
forcément les candidats font des
promesses aussi mais comment on finance
qui aura pas assez nos confères
l'épreuve non les impôts nommé j'ai dans
mes propositions une proposition
concernant les seniors qui sont isolées
du centre village alors moi je veux bien
qu'on m'explique qu'on n'a pas les
moyens en 2017 la ville de voisins et un
fonds de roulement de 7 millions d'euros
7 millions d'euros on envisage
d'ailleurs de payer notre participation
sur le projet de la remise
je vais dire cash c'est à dire qu'au
lieu de faire un emprunt pour financer
un quartier et que les nouveaux
habitants aux faux participe au
financement de ce nouveau quartier on va
sortir du cash pour financer la partie
de boisement la gestion un départ n'est
pas mon avis idéal aujourd'hui je pense
qu'on a les moyens d'agir
mais prenons le cas les personnes âgées
aujourd'hui si on ne fait rien pour des
raisons financières ça veut dire qu'on
va laisser nos personnes âgées qui sont
dans les quartiers excentrés du
centre-village voient leur dire bah
écoutez on peut rien faire alors on
pouvait sortir trois cent cinquante
mille euros pour faire des paddle ou des
panels pardon
pour faire plaisir je dirais à des amis
parce que c'était le cas par contre on
peut pas sortir un peu d'argent pour
financer une navette qui recherchait nos
seniors qui peuvent pas et placés ou les
personnes à mobilité réduite
moi je crois que vous savez c'est
peut-être aussi je sais pas je subviens
du monde de l'entreprise je pense que
aujourd'hui l'humain doit être au coeur
de nos préoccupations
je pense aussi que le cadre de vie des
vies si noah doit être au coeur de nos
décisions et le financement
c'est une réaffectation des budgets
cette augmentation d'impôts non mon
objectif c'est pas augmenter les impôts
mais quand bien même je vais vous dire
il faut être honnête dans cette élection
moi j'entends beaucoup de vie sinon nous
expliquer mais moi je suis prêt à ce
qu'on augmente les impôts et qu'on paye
l'amendé pour pas avoir de logements
sociaux ce qui est pas du tout ce que je
pense
donc si vous l'avez vie si noah sont des
gens lucides qui veulent se donner les
moyens d'avoir un cadre de vie agréable
or le cadre de la vie aujourd'hui à
voisins force est de constater qu'ils se
démerdent un dernier mot nous arrivons
dans la dernière minute de cet entretien
la suite de votre campagne
et oui déjà ça fait presque dix minutes
ses derniers mots dont concernant la
suite de votre campagne les rendez-vous
a annoncé prochain rendez vous pour vous
alors le tous les mercredis de 18h à 20h
je suis dans une brasserie lave la
providence qui est au coeur au coeur de
ville j'invite les missions à venir me
parler je sais qu'en ce moment beaucoup
de rumeurs circulent c'est la loi du
genre
je les invite à ce rendez vous ça permet
d'avoir un face à face direct et
d'échangé et jeux sur le financement
vous avez raison c'est il y aura de
toute façon c'est ce que j'avais fait
pour la circulation je ferai pour le
reste je publierai le
les financements comme enjeu financement
programme mais attend la même chose de
mes concurrents vous aurez l'occasion
d'échanger avec vos différents
concurrents lors d'un débat qui sera
proposé prochainement sur notre antenne
ce sera le 22 février merci d'être venus
merci je rappelle que vous êtes candidat
donc sur voisins le bretonneux alexandra
rosetti maire sortante elle aussi est
candidate elle sera l'invitée du 7-8
politique mardi prochain merci à vous
nous quittons voisins le bretonneux pour
guyancourt à présent maire sortant
françois à morton présente sa liste
complète ce mardi soir aux habitants à
la ferme de bel ébat il vient également
de dévoiler ses propositions elles sont
au nombre de 100 une centaine parmi
lesquels étendre les horaires de la
police municipale la nuit encore à la
mise en place de conseils d'usagé dans
les structures municipales de porte en
porte dans le quartier du pont du rotois
raguy en cours françois morton maire
sortant de la commune est parti à la
rencontre des habitants pour présenter
son programme et sa liste guyancourt
pour tous bonjour madame françois morton
maire de guyancourt
on vient à la rencontre des habitants
vous pouvez nous ouvrir la porte
ce programme il est prêt puisqu'il a été
distribué dans l'ensemble des boîtes aux
lettres de la ville de guyancourt la
semaine dernière donc dans les douze
mille boîtes aux lettres de la ville
ce programme il est il est issu d'un
certain nombre de constats qui ont été
effectués durant tout le mandat
dernier mais aussi et bien évidemment du
travail qu'on a pu faire en
collaboration avec les habitants
lors de nos ateliers citoyens du mois de
novembre un programme proposé en trois
grandes parties
tout citoyen tout solidaire et vivre
tous ensemble avec douze thématiques et
une centaine de points précis comme la
construction de logements adaptés à tous
les revenus
l'extension de la faculté de médecine
sur la commune ou encore la rénovation
de nouvelles voiries
certaines sont tout à fait transversales
comme par exemple la transition
écologique dans toutes ses dimensions
d'ailleurs environnemental mais aussi
social et économique
alors vous avez la tranquillité publique
vous avez l'éducation bien évidemment
qui reste un pilier fort de notre
programme
et puis toutes les questions sont
abordées en n'éludant aucune
le programme est à retrouver dans les
boîtes aux lettres en attendant françois
morton d'oeuvre rendez vous au
guyancourt toi le 3 mars prochain pour
une nouvelle réunion publique elle aussi
candidate à sa succession nelly duthu
poursuit sa campagne à la verrière nous
étions présents lors de sa dernière
réunion publique en date voici quelques
jours une liste renouvelée avec des
jeunes issus de l'ensemble des quartiers
de la ville voilà les membres de
l'équipe la verrière en commun mené par
nelly duthu avec un projet politique
sociale et écologique pour les habitants
en fait sur un peu des trois quartiers à
la base je suis vraiment originaire du
bois de l'étang
gg j'ai vécu 27 ans j'ai vécu aussi à
orly parc et au village donc c'est vrai
moi j'ai vraiment une vue d'ensemble de
la ville au niveau du conseil municipal
si on peut favoriser la solidarité
l'aide de l'aide aux gens bages et
j'essaierai de faire mon possible
plusieurs mesures pour l'insertion
professionnelle la création d'une régie
de quartier instance dirigée par des
habitants et des élus pour développer
des services et embaucher des habitants
autres mesures pour favoriser l'emploi
obtenir un chargé de mission sur ce
domaine avec plusieurs objectifs prendre
contact avec les entreprises
faire connaître la verrière montrer aux
entreprises que les ans les jeunes ou
les moins jeunes de la verrière on peut
leur faire confiance
autre point avoir plus de produits
locaux et bio dans la restauration
scolaire et à terme l'idée d'une cuisine
centrale pour confectionner les repas
des élèves de la verrière
je crois très sincèrement que les
enfants ont droit à cette cuisine qui
donne des repas de meilleure qualité où
on peut justement faire attention à ce
qu'on met dans l'assiette sur les grands
projets nelly duthu souhaite poursuivre
le projet zac gare bécane et assurer la
rénovation du quartier du bois de
l'étang sans destruction
c'est la fin de ce set 8 politique la
campagne est à suivre chaque jour dans
le journal dès 18h et puis les replays
ville par ville sur notre site internet
et applications mobiles ne manquez pas
non plus nos premiers débats à suivre
sur cette antenne à partir du 8 février
c'est un week-end rendez-vous samedi
donc bonne soirée
[Musique]